antwerp is a city known for its fashion
and now there is a familiar accessory
masks are mandatory here a response to a
dramatic resurgence in coronavirus
at this shop the demand has been
enormous this is our best sellers at the
moment
since uh it has been uh yeah we've been
informed that the the infection is uh
really bad in antwerp cases of the virus
have risen by 77
across belgium the governor of this
province has told people
to avoid coming to the city almost half
of the new infections that
we see every day in belgium half of them
occur in antwerp
so that means that really the cluster
and the outbreak is really situated in
antwerp
so why the resurgence she told me
belgium is paying the price for
optimism and a lack of scrutiny do you
agree
that the lockdown was eased a little too
soon
i fully agree especially for antwerp
well they worked with some parameters
like the
r reproduction rate they made the
calculation on that reproduction
rate for the entire of the country if it
would have been
applied on android itself they would
have seen that it was still
rather high in the middle of antwerp a
statue remembering the legend of its
founder slaying an
evil giant resilience is in the
character here but it's now mixed with
fear
i am very anxious to be
in the neighborhood of people so i i
keep my social distance
and more if it is possible i'm an a
little bit
older man and i am afraid
yes it's like there's a another lockdown
but
people are more scared to come on out on
the street and
it's yeah it's it's it's very weird
it's the same across the city people
throughout belgium
anxious that recent history will repeat
itself a lot of people in antwerp
suspect
that a mandatory lockdown is coming but
what they don't know
is whether that will be local to this
city or maybe
for the whole country everybody the end
of the last lockdown was greeted with
delight but maybe that wave of euphoria
was the problem
so it is indeed a second wave that
starts starts quickly shows really that
if you don't
respect physical distancing that this
infection
spreads around very easily and then it's
again
it requests major measures to to start
controlling it again
professor van dam is leading a team
working on a vaccine but it won't come
for a year at the earliest
in the piece of antwerp the second wave
is building
and its ripples are beginning to spread
adam parsons sky news antwerp
you